I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT AIN'T
GONNA MESS UP OUR FRIENDSHIP.
[sheep baas]
AAH! OW!
WHAT THE HELL Y'ALL DOIN'?
- EVICTING YOU
FOR TEARING UP MY PARK!
- THAT WASN'T ME,
THAT WAS "DRUNK BOBBY."
IF YOU WANNA TALK TO HIM,
HE'LL BE HERE IN 12 OUNCES.
- HAPPY HOUR'S OVER,
SWAMP PEOPLE!
YOU ARE HEREBY BEING KICKED
THE HELL OUT OF MY PARK!
- HUH. THIS LOOKS LIKE
IT'S FROM THE OLDEN TIMES.
WHAT IS IT?
- HOW AM I SUPPOSED TO KNOW
WHAT THE HELL IT IS?
IT'S GOT WORDS AND SHIT
ON IT.
- WOW...1880s, DA DA DA.
CIVIL WAR...YOUR COUSIN...
"REGINALD WOOTEN POSSUMCODS..."
OH, MY GOD.
ACCORDING TO THIS,
YOU'RE THE HEIR
TO BRICKLEBERRY PARK.
- WHOO!
WAIT A MINUTE,
DID HE CALL ME A QUEER?
- GIVE ME THAT!
OOH...
ACTUALLY, ROBERT,
WHAT IT REALLY SAYS IS,
AND I QUOTE,
THERE IS NO GODDAMN WAY IN HELL
THAT ASSHOLE BOBBY POSSUMCODS
OWNS THIS PARK!
- DON'T GET MORE OFFICIAL
THAN THAT.
- THAT'S NOT WHAT IT SAYS.
IT SAYS RIGHT HERE
BOBBY OWNS THE PARK, AND--UNH!
- OH, I KNOW WHAT
IT SAYS NOW.
IT SAYS GET THE HELL
OFF MY PROPERTY!
♪
- OW! OOOW!
[bird chirping, gunshot]